you got a big show
thank you i know you're so i'm happy too
i'm i don't know why i hate to ruin your
summer um but i
it's my job to report the news and
there's just this terrible fight going
on now in ukraine you heard there's a
war there oh my gosh and they're they're
fighting near the biggest nuclear plant
in europe and if they break it this
could be bad
uh yeah that they say that it could the
fallout could spread to all these
eastern european countries slovenia
slovakia it could threaten trump's
entire wife's supply
so we're looking at this situation
[Applause]
trump
when is this man not going to be in the
news
now we're in like week three of box gate
you know
when they went down to mar-a-lago the
fbi to get his boxes and you know every
week now we hear different stories about
why he is okay to have taken these from
magaland
you know it's like they weren't
classified okay they were classified but
then they were magically declassified
and latest they're planted the fbi
planted them
in a related story uh deshaun watson
today said that uh
two dozen massage therapists planted his
dick in their
hand right
rudy giuliani yes
he said it's okay that trump stole this
stuff because you know they're they're
in a place that's just as safe as the
place they originally were and everybody
knows that's the rule you're allowed to
take [ __ ] if it's in a safe place
i wouldn't try this in real life i
didn't rob that drug store uh no it's
just uh in my safe house this stuff
right there
and oh
and
and now it's funny the republicans very
against the fbi now there were always
the law and order people right now to
defund the fbi get rid of the fbi the
fbi
am i the only one remembering this
they're the squares
they iron their underwear that's who the
fbi is they're dull they're from the
1950s
it's like bitching that there's nothing
good on cbs
i did cvs
we're at cbs
we love cbs
see the [ __ ] thing fall on my head
but i tell you this strategy is working
we're coming to the end of primary
season trump is one 85 percent of the
people he endorsed liz cheney got tossed
on her ass in wyoming by 37 points the
republicans there were like who likes
elections now [ __ ]
but the truth is most residents of
wyoming just relate more to trump
because most residents of wyoming are
cows
[Music]
and
the person who's taking this cheney spot
here in wyoming named harriet hegman
used to be an anti-trumper called them
all the names that people call trump and
then of course wanted a job switched up
and trump loves this is what trump loves
the most when he flips someone who used
to be against him it's like a pimp
turning out a virgin you know it's
like but
he's got four investigations now against
him and the people he worked with are
being rolled up wiseman is the money man
guy he pleaded guilty this week 15
counts uh rudy giuliani had to sit for
six hours of testimony lindsey graham a
federal judge said he must testify there
in georgia about trump trying to [ __ ]
with the election there and lindsey
graham said he is not going to cooperate
uh but he always wanted to be the target
of a probe i i don't know
i don't know what that means but
you